They're longtime rivals in the comics, but
Spider-Man failed to appear in Venom's solo
big-screen debut.
Why?
Isn't this a Marvel movie?
Well, kinda.
The answer's actually a lot more complicated
than that.
If you want to know the real reason why Spider-Man's
not in the Venom movie, we've got to talk
some business.
House divided
Marvel movies didn't really become "Marvel
movies" as you know them until 2008's Iron
Man.
In the 1990s, Marvel's moviemaking division
was still trying to convince Hollywood that
movies and TV shows based on its comic books
might be something worth looking into.
Since it had no direct leverage in the film
industry, Marvel farmed its properties out
to anyone who would take a chance on using
them.
This is how Fox ended up making the X-Men
and Fantastic Four movies, how Universal ended
up in charge of the Hulk, and why Spider-Man
and his Amazing spider-friends ended up in
the hands of Sony.
This is how things used to be.
But the success of Iron Man and the birth
of Marvel Studios changed all that, getting
the mighty Marvel movie party in motion.
Marvel Studios has since been acquired by
Disney, which more recently began the process
of acquiring Fox, which brings a large chunk
of the Marvel characters back under one roof,
except for Sony's spider-people.
And that's where things get dicey.
"None of this makes sense"
Unamazing Spider-plan
The same year that Marvel Studios took its
burgeoning cinematic universe to the next
level with The Avengers, Sony rebooted its
Spider-Man franchise with The Amazing Spider-Man.
And Sony's plans didn't stop with Peter Parker.
In an effort to compete with the rising MCU,
Sony began laying track for its own cinematic
universe set in the world of Spider-Man's
New York.
During the production of Amazing Spider-Man
2, reports emerged that Sony was developing
a movie based on the villain team the Sinister
Six.
There were also rumors of a potential Venom
spinoff, as well as a prequel movie focusing
on a young Aunt May, a mind-boggling proposition,
both then and also now.
"Hey.
Hey!
Hey, whaddaya doin, whaddaya doin, whaddaya
doin?
no, I do the laundry."
None of it panned out once the Amazing Spider-Man
sequel debuted to a franchise-low performance,
leading Sony to re-evaluate its entire approach
to the Spider-Man property.
In doing so, they leaned into a classic survival
strategy, if you can't beat 'em, join 'em.
Homecoming
By 2014, Sony and Marvel were officially in
talks to collaborate on producing a second
Spider-Man reboot, talks which ultimately
culminated in 2017's Spider-Man: Homecoming.
The team-up arrangement sported benefits for
both parties.
Creatively, the arrangement allowed Marvel
Studios to use Spider-Man in its own MCU stories,
while Sony got to reap some profits off of
Marvel's golden touch.
The deal has been reported to cover the production
of five movies total, with the fifth being
2019's Spider-Man: Far From Home.
After that, no one's really sure what's going
to happen, either Sony will take back control
of Spider-Man, or the studios will continue
to share him.
In the meantime, the finer details of who
gets to do what with which Marvel characters
can be kind of confusing for the rest of us.
Muddying the waters
In 2017, Sony announced a standalone movie
for Venom, one of the most famous Marvel Comics
characters that it owns the rights to.
The announcement almost immediately sparked
confusion about the movie's place in the MCU,
if it had a place at all.
People wondered: Would Venom take place in
the same world as the Iron Man, Black Panther,
and the Guardians of the Galaxy?
Or would it be doing its own thing?
Even the people in charge of making the movies
couldn't get their story straight when talking
with the media.
It was eventually cleared up that the MCU
would have nothing to do with the movies that
Sony made on its own.
Basically, Marvel gets to handle the live-action
Spider-Man appearances, and everything Sony
does is Sony's business.
Rumors abound
Sony began making the Venom movie with Tom
Hardy in the lead, drawing inspiration from
a comic that put the character in San Francisco.
His costume was also altered to remove any
traces of Spider-Man's arachnid DNA.
On top of that, the movie's director explicitly
said that Spider-Man would not be in the movie,
which should have been the end of the debate.
But rumors still persisted that Spider-Man
would appear.
One of the more pervasive rumors claimed that
current Spider-Man actor Tom Holland would
be appearing in Venom, just as Peter Parker,
and not suited up as Spider-Man.
The rumor, most predominantly pushed by Collider's
Jon Schnepp, has a certain kind of logic to
it.
After all, a Peter Parker appearance would
mean that all those denials of a Spider-Man
appearance would technically be correct.
"You are Technically correct, the best kind of correct."
SUMC vs. MCU
Of course, as we all know now, neither Spider-Man,
Peter Parker, nor Tom Holland is anywhere
near the Venom movie as we saw it in theaters.
Indeed, Venom is the start of something new,
which Sony plans to use as a springboard for
a new attempt at a cinematic universe.
According to Variety, the series is being
internally referred to as "Sony's Universe
of Marvel Characters", which is not a great
name, but hey, it's what we've got for now.
The question is, who's next?
Sony is reportedly now in development on several
movies based on the Marvel Comics characters
to which it owns the film rights, a number
that Variety puts at around 900.
Current movies in development include a Morbius,
the Living Vampire movie starring Jared Leto,
as well as movies based off of the characters
Jackpot, Black Cat, Kraven the Hunter, Nightwatch,
Silk, and Silver Sable, and those are just
the ones we know about.
So will these movies actually come to fruition?
Probably not all of them.
But the strong performance of Venom would
seem to put the studio in a good position
for the future, Spider-Man or no Spider-Man.